-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"My dumb bet" stories
from you guys.
This first one
is from @gumgumerson.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Interesting first name.
-Gum.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Grow up, dude.
-"Wake up!"
-This next one's from
@missgreenwalt.
She says...
-Yeah!
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Living the life, man.
-Yeah.
Two beds.
-This one's from @mrcooperclark.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Samuelel.
-Samuel.
-Samuelel, Samuelel.
-Yeah, from the Bible.
-Samuelel.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @logylogues.
-Oh, logy logues.
[ Laughter ]
-I wonder if they're friends
with Gum Gumerson.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He says...
There you go.
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh!
-That's pretty bad.
That's a pretty bad bet
right there, yeah.
-Now you gotta pay the bets.
-Lost by a hair. Oh.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
That's all right.
Don't get hurt, anybody.
This one's from @CraigLefferts.
He said...
[ Laughter ]
"I just thought the Tigers
had a chance, that's all.
Let's go get ice cream!"
-"When you lost."
-This one's from @vestureuk.
He says...
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Oh.
Why would you bet that?
-Wow.
Wow.
-What would be worth it?
-That's fantastic.
This last one's
from @rockefeller88.
He says...
There you go, everybody.
-Those are my
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.